all right thank you for the introduction
thank you for the very nice talk you one
second setup so I first met Michael when
he was in his last year as an undergrad
at MIT he was taking an advanced data
structures class that I was Tien for the
first time that was set up as an open
problem session for the bulk of the
class which which was great so the
professor so yeah most of the classes
were set up where we give like an easy
problem that was solved like an open
problem and we go around talking with
the students and right Michael as you
can see from the G chats he was just
full of these like short snippets of
like oh did you know you could improve
this this way here's a much cleaner
answer this than this have you thought
about this problem and it always be a
mix of like some of them would just be
clean and you'd get rid of the way some
we're like really good at hooking you
like asking you a question you thought
you knew the answer to and then he would
turn it on its head and realize there's
something much more complicated there
and he had a really nice answer
so yeah this whole class Michael was
full of these things and this was
responsible perhaps for the one maybe
not positive ta review I got over the
course of the class where someone wrote
at the very end of like yeah the TAS are
pretty good just they seemed easily
distracted by the students who want to
talk about some sort of unrelated
problems in the material of the class so
that was my first experience with
Michael and it was pretty characteristic
of working with him then on whenever you
pick a problem he would just keep
generating these sort of very nice
insights all around and you know little
things to push problems but what I
wanted to tell you about today was I
think the first time I had a more
serious conversation about any of these
things with him it's the first problem I
maybe worked with him at all on and it's
a problem I worked with him on and off I
guess over a number of years since so
I'm gonna the point of this talks is to
you know tell you I guess a bit about
the problem my thinking on the problem
and give you enough information that you
can appreciate like
simplicity and what Michael did when he
looked at the problem and get a taste of
some of the things he was working on
over the last few years that aren't out
in the literature that need to be out in
the literature and some cool things that
happen along the way all right so that's
what the talk is gonna be about the talk
is a write entitled Michael and Cowan
and oblivious routing this talk will be
about oblivious routing and basically a
bunch of things Michael taught me over
the course of the WA the last number of
years all right for those of you that
know oblivious routing well some of this
might be sort of known but I hope we
want to demonstrate I think the
simplicity and beauty and some of the
things he came up with along the way all
right so the rest of talk the main thing
I'll be talking about is oblivious
routing this is one of maybe my favorite
problems in combinatorial optimization
and online algorithms I guess he had
been working on online algorithms for a
period of time
and the problem is as follows so we're
giving his input some large undirected
graph G
so some really large complicated
undirected graph has some n vertices V M
edges E and some non-negative capacities
you alright the other thing we get is
input to this problem is some secrets of
demands
so I demand I simply mean some vector
some vector over the vertices of the
graphs these are d1 through DK that
simply each specify how much flow should
enter leave some vertex of the graph so
the first demand might be one in at this
vertex one out at that this vertex the
demand d2 might mean like half a unit
comes in here a quarter unit comes out
here and a quarter unit comes out here
so demands are just some vectors on the
vertices of the graph that sum up to
zero meaning the total amount that
should go into the graph should be the
total amount that comes out and the goal
of the problem is what we want to output
is some sequence of flows f1 through FDA
over the edges of the and these flows
are simply assignments of real values
the edges of the graphs they simply
specify how much flow goes into each
direction every edge and these flows
have to have the property that the flows
each flow fi routes the demand di for
all I because I can't help it at times
in the tack talk I might use this
notation a B transpose fi to denote the
flow routed by Fi
so that Phi is just these real values
assigned to every vertex of the graph to
route a set of demands that are out
simply corresponds to for a flow at
every vertex how much the net flow that
goes in and out and for float or out a
demand it means the net flow going in
and out should be what specified by the
demands so for the first demand that was
one in here and one out here the flow
might be some SD path that sends one
unit from s to T for this one it might
be something that sends 1/2 unit for a
while and splits up into smaller things
going in each direction and there are
gold
is to get the best routing of the mats
okay now for this to be a well specified
problem I need to tell you what I mean
by best have to specify what's the
objective under which we want to get
these flows surrounding the demands and
the one for the most common ones cited
for the oblivious routing problem is
congestion this will be our benchmark
for how ideally we'd want to route the
flow subjects to the mend
and we'll say that for some set of flows
fi the congestion it has on some edge e
is simply the total amount of flow over
this edge divided by the capacity of the
edge alright and we'll say that the
congestion over all of the flows is
simply the most any edge is congested
and ideally if we had no other demands
we knew the graph and we had all the
input what we want to do is get the flow
that routes the man's that has minimal
congestion and I'll denote that optimal
congestion by Optive di this is simply
the minimum over all the flows that
routes the demands the congestion of
every one of the flows all right so the
idea here is we should think like maybe
the graph here corresponds to links on
the Internet we're getting a bunch of
requests people wanting to get
information from different points and we
can't do what we want to have is that no
network edge in the network is utilized
too much right and ideally this is what
we'd want to solve so this particular
problem of minimizing congestion it's
also known as the you know under skip
after scaling is basically the
concurrent multi commodity flow problem
in general it's expensive to compute you
need to look at all the demands in the
entire graph this could be a fairly
expensive optimization problem so with
the linear oblivia what the oblivious
routing question asks is maybe is there
some way to solve this problem
approximately with a much more simple
operator in particular what I'll call
the linear oblivious routing problem
asks is maybe instead of trying to solve
this complicated joint optimization
problem where we look at how these
demands interact and try to send pick
flows accordingly instead let's just try
to pick a fix scheme for how we would
route every single demand and use that
as an approximation all right so we call
an operator R that's just a mapping from
the vertices the edges an oblivious a
linear oblivious routing if it has the
property that it's a linear mapping
it takes as input demands and it outputs
flows so these assignments the edges
that route the defense
this is what we'll call it linear
oblivious writing this is linear
mappings from what the imbalance is
every vertex does some ploy that Rao
said so if the demand is wanting at s1
RT and might spit out a path or its
distribution overpass routing to it all
right now the question we want to ask is
if we commit to a linear oblivious
routing scheme instead of solving this
joint optimization problem how good can
we get how well does such an oblivious
routing scheme to and formally the
oblivious routing problem
then asks is there such a scheme it does
as well as optin
all right so can we get one scheme that
if we read our demands by our it does
almost as well as we one would hope to
do if they solve the full joint
optimization problem so formally we
denote we did call this the competitive
ratio of an oblivious routing scheme the
noted Rho of R and it's simply the
largest over every sequence of demands
you could possibly get the congestion
incurred by routing the demands using R
divided by the optimal congestion so how
much more do we congest things if we
reroute everything using our fixed
scheme that use nothing about the joint
sequence of demands we could possibly
see how much larger is the congestion of
that as compared to the optimal
congestion right so the oblivious yeah
[Music]
yeah right so the oblivious starting
problem Jenny would ask overall Gore
what's the overall graphs so this is the
competitive ratio in a single oblivious
routing like once I fix one its
competitive ratios the worse this ratio
can be and in general the question is
going to be you know one Kenton we
always so for all graphs find our with
good a competitive ratio and two can we
find it quickly
so that's the problem it's the ref
problem Michael and I have talked on and
off for the I guess a number of years in
a variety of contexts and I think what I
want to tell you about is roughly how
one would go about solving the problem
what the algorithms look like and his a
very simple insight that got rid of what
I thought was some very needed machinery
so the first time I think he caught me
in one of these like Oh pretty sure
there's a much simpler way to do any of
this and hopefully in talking about how
you would go about solving this from
home you can get a little bit more of an
appreciation I think for some of the
improvements he shared along the way and
was working on all right so that's the
question the question is clear can we
always find the oblivia starting with a
good competitive ratio and how fast can
we find it quick aside why would you
want to solve this problem first it's
just a natural online problem you know
you can imagine we're only getting the
demands one at a time so we have the
internet we're getting a request to send
one unit from s to t we're getting one
year to send somewhere else we're
getting them one at a time when we
immediately want to respond with the
flow routing each of those demands
you know this is giving a solution to
that online problem because you given
every demand you could just read it
using our and how well you would do the
actual competitive ratio of that scheme
like the congestion you get versus if
you had done everything with a joint
optimization problem at the end we'd be
given by the competitive ratio so it's a
natural online problem if it's a
solvable at all if you can get a good
competitive ratio it says something very
interesting about I think the structure
of multi commodity flow and undirected
graphs
the answers for this along the lines
that solving this seems like you'd have
to have some interesting structural
decomposition of your undirected graph
correspondingly algorithms for this have
been used to get better approximation
algorithms for a whole host of problems
I believe the fastest the best
approximation ratios for graft bisection
still go through oblivious routing
insights and I guess the reason I
originally looked at as you can it's
been shown over the last years you can
use algorithms for solving this to get
faster algorithms for solving flow
problems so things like max flow D
commodity flow
right good all right so with this
motivation in mind okay what were the
previous best what are the best known
running times for solving this problem
there's a long line of work there's a
long line of work on solving this
problem so here I'm going to use a T of
R to denote the time needed to apply to
sorry to compute R and apply it and its
transpose
there's a long line of interesting work
on this problem I guess the first time
you think about one the reason I find it
exciting is it's not even clear
immediately that there is you can get
row afar to be bounded you might worry
there's some sequence of demands that
you keep breaking things up in some
weird way to make the congestion on an
edge grow and grow and grow there was a
long line of work showing that not only
is row of are bounded and you can get a
competitive ratio bound a competitive
ratio but after a long line of work that
I can't quite do justice to there was
this beautiful result of Reiki in 2008
so you can always get a competitive
ratio of log n so you can get that how
much worse the oblivious crowding does
than multi commodity flow grows fairly
slowly with a number of vertices and you
can get that you can apply it in a
pretty reasonable amount of time and get
something quadratic in the number of
edges this was improved in joint work
with John Kilmer in Tetley and Renzo
recchia to get something where it's
almost a constant the Confederation you
can play an almost linear time but it
was you can do this using some insights
of a cool paper in lodging 2010 but it
was horribly complicated then I think
this is fairly if this is fairly
straightforward if you know how frt
works and that's what I'll touch on
really briefly and motivate why you have
to do something complicated and why
Michael showed you don't have to do
something so complicated yeah so like
the time to like look at our D and our
transpose e for some vectors DNA
yeah but but so that's why being able to
play no tilde M is a non-trivial so this
is true oh but the time to construct it
as well you can imagine constructing the
oblivious routing is very complicated
but good point the time to apply it you
could bound that way assuming it's
explicit oh so it's something I'm using
a double tilde to be something that's
between that's a smaller than any
polynomial but larger than poly luck
yeah I probably shouldn't have just used
that off the it works twice on the
whiteboard and horrible and later okay
all right so this is what I want to tell
you about and then sort of the cool work
Michael did going off of this down the
road all right so the question clear the
result clear yeah this is tight yeah
good question this is tight you can't do
better yeah expanders sparse expanders
yeah any other questions
okay all right so how do you do this so
I'm gonna go really quickly I think
through the history of those results on
how to do it so you can see Michaels
much much simpler scheme which is good
to erase erase this okay so how do you
do this I think there is two main ideas
needed to understand the results they're
fairly short
so the first idea okay so the first
thing if you want to go to construct
these things you would ask for a routing
scheme how do I actually get a handle on
its competitive ratio actually trying to
go through this formula might be a bit
complicated trying to reason about the
worst case demand sequence gets quite
complicated but using the fact that we
restricted our attention to linear
oblivious routing so it's just some
linear operator are you can actually
show there's a really short formula for
the competitive ratio it's just equal to
this where u is the diagonal matrix
corresponding to the capacities all
right so now it should all be clear okay
so what does this actually mean this is
just a very very concise way of setting
the competitive ratio of an oblivious
routing scheme is the congestion
incurred when you route the graph
obliviously on itself
so you fixed some linear routing scheme
now imagine for every single edge you
think you know an edge is just has two
endpoints some a and B it has some
capacity
imagine routing capacity units of flow
from A to B and do this for every single
edge in the graph all right so take that
as your demand set route every that is
your demand side obliviously look at the
worst congestion in every edge turns out
that's exactly equal to the competitive
ratio if you think about it that's what
this is a shorthand for alright so what
this means what this means is for the
sake of trying to bound the oblivious
routing we like we know the worst demand
set
the worst demands are simply when you
route every single edge in the graph
corresponding to its capacity so if you
think of the oblivious writing a sort of
embedding the gret on a cell a graph on
itself that's the worst case scenario
you just need to bound that all right so
that's the first idea so this tells us
at least what to aim for and how to
reason about the quality of an oblivious
routing the second idea it appeared and
various forms on the work is that you
don't have to construct the oblivious
routing all at once there's ways to
compute it by reducing to simpler graphs
all right
so suppose we want to get our oblivious
routing for G and we have some graphs h1
through a che right now so these are
just some graphs that we're gonna try to
reduce routing computing oblivious
routing on G to computing oblivious
writings on these graphs all right
suppose G embeds in a chai with can for
every eye with congestion row I wrote
one meaning we can take every edge in
the graph and map it to some path in H I
right and the ultimate congestion
incurred when doing that for every edge
in gh is Row one further was suppose we
have routings a I for each H I with
congestion sorry with a row of AI equal
to row two
so for every one of the AIS we do
compute some oblivious routing and
finally suppose we have some embeddings
and one through m'kay take every one of
each of them takes the graph H I and
embeds it back in G so every gaijin h i
gets mapped to some path in G I all
right and suppose this has the property
that if you look at the congestion yeah
of the avert the congestion of embedding
every one of the G is with the mi back
into so if you look at the kink of sorry
so we have these embeddings than 1
through m k we have that take every one
of the h eyes and map them back to G now
imagine what we do is we look at the
graph that's like the distribution over
H I've right we look at the congestion
incurred from embedding that
distribution so for every we wrapped
like a 1 over K fraction of every one of
the H is back on the graph if you
overall congestion let's assume the
overall congestion of that is Rho 3
right meaning like the total expected
congestion when rerouting all the H is
back and G is some number oh three all
right so our graph embeds into every one
of the H I H is we have good routings
and then the H is an expectation route
back into embed back into our graph
alright if you have this then you have
that the competitive ratio of simply
routing obliviously in every one of the
GIS and then embedding back into the
graph the competitive ratio of this is
simply the product of these three
numbers what they're saying is you have
your very complicated graph you have a
bunch of simpler graphs then you know
how to route in to route your demands
here simply route your demands in each
of these and then embed it back in the
graph and as long as you have these
properties you get a good competitive
ratio at the end
all right those tools in hand that's
about the the bulk of what you need to
understand I think oh you would actually
go about constructing these oblivious
writings weh-weh Reiki oh it actually
worked as they showed that if what you
do is you take any distribution over the
edges of the graph so you have some
distribution over the edges in the
original graph you want
they showed there exists some graph H
that depends only on this distribution P
such that is that is a tree I'll call it
t P so there's a graph so there's some
tree depends only on the distribution of
the this distribution P that has the
following three properties one you can
show that G embeds
into this tree with congestion 1 2 there
is of one oblivious routing
I'm TP this is immediate for trees
there's only one ways to route so just
routing on a tree the only way you could
pot like if you don't want unit here
there's only one path there's only one
way to rat anything so there's the
trivial routing is always no of one
competitive ratio or one competitive
ratio and three there is an embedding
from gp2 G so that the expected
congestion on each of the edges
when you look at expectation by P so you
pick an edge with probability by
proportional to P and then look at the
congestion on that edge when embedding
from the tree back into the graph you
can show that that is o of log n this is
essentially using frt very cool result
of front row and tour and yeah I tried
to how do I pronounce it properly huh
thank you
and the worst case congestion is o of n
all right so what this means is you have
any distribution of the edges you can
get a tree based routing that where the
expected congestion in every edge is
bounded it so vloggin and the worst that
any gadget is congestion is o of n all
right so what this essentially saying is
we have our graph for any distribution
we could find a tree that inside it
should essentially think that we find in
treating the site shows the expected
congestion is small but we actually want
you know is what we want to have is not
that for a fixed distribution the
congestion is small we want to have that
you know we want to get a bunch of trees
such that if I look at the congestion in
every edge averaged over all the trees
this is log n right and if you know
multiplicative weights well this is a
primitive if you play the right game on
how you play with a distribution the
media implies this and the fact that
every edge no edge is congestion more
than m tells you only need to do M trees
that's essentially the proof ok so the
big problem with actually running this
is that it's rather slow all right so
this shows that you can get a
competitive ratio of log n but the time
is m squared right and the time is M
Squared for rather fundamental reason
you know the number you know if one tree
is congested by M then if you want to
average
over a number of trees for nothing to be
congested too much you need to take em
trees right so even if you just take
like a very simple graph of like a bunch
of parallel paths in parallel sorry just
em parallel redundant edges you know any
tree that you pick you're going to try
to route em units on it's gonna get very
congested you kind of need to take a
large number of trees before you get any
sort of real runtime improvement all
right so this is sort of the big
bottleneck in trying to make this
efficient there was a really nice right
there was a really nice idea from Adri
ten showed a very nice idea said you
know maybe so the bottleneck here is
that however much an edge is congested
is going to boil down to the number of
trees you actually need to compute so
the idea is instead of trying to compute
all the trees at once maybe we'll try to
just compute a slightly simpler object
with better congestion so we don't need
as many and we'll do the construction
recursively so the idea was still take a
tree look at the congestion incurred
when you route every edge over the tree
all right now if an edge and then the
idea is simply if an edge is congested
keep it so keep it and all the edges
that go over it in some way so it
doesn't count to your overall congested
and the I key idea is that not too many
edges in the tree
and be congested so if you look at sort
of the bottleneck edges if you look at
these congested edges and try to route
towards them you can show right so I
used to take the congested edges try to
route all the edges not in the tree Oh
towards these congested edges and reduce
it to some graph where the edges are
only incident on the congested edges and
if you do this carefully you can bring
down the congestion you can show that
you can recurse instead of needing to
work compute oblivious routing on em
graphs you can show that you need to
only reduce on km graphs for any
parameter k with o of M K vertices all
right it's actually make progress you
sparsa phi the graph so that M is on the
order of N and argh you can always
rehearse on a smaller graph so the big
problem in doing any of this is sparse
vacation
so we water work when we wanted to try
to use any of this to get a oblivious
routing this was the big bottleneck to
overcome that somehow you sort of needed
to sparse a fire graph so you can turn
average congestion onto tree into
average congestion only around a few
vertices and have something smaller to
recurse on so the way we got around this
is we had a very very horrible solution
where we showed that what you can do is
you can break your graph I was I say it
out loud actually because I'm running a
little low on time and I want to talk
more about Michael's work to get around
this problem we had a complicated thing
where we said take your graph right so
the problem we have is we have a dense
graph we want to spar safai it and
reduce constructing believe is starting
the dense graph to construed
constructing Bluebird starting on a
sparse graph so we did is we showed a
very complicated scheme we broke the
graph into expanders showed you could
sub sample averages from every expander
route the expanders back on the original
graph using electric flows prove some
properties about electric flows on the
electric flows within subsets of
expanders do this with the right
recursion and the right subset of
expanders property and it solves that
sub problem all right
so this happened some point earlier in
grad school I don't know I was pretty
proud of it I'm not I'm not sure if
you're in tech feels the same way and
there I am talking with Michael I think
he's he was there for prospective
student visit days to decide we go to
grad school and he's chatting casually
about the paper and I think the phrase I
said it was something like I'm sure
you've all heard something like this
it's like you know you don't need that
right this is like multiple pages of
complicated complicated analysis he's
like yeah they get around this issue of
like sparsa fiying yet don't don't do
any of that he said you know just sparsa
phi the graph like you normally would
you know and normally the way you do
that is you just pick every edge with
some sampling probability like there's a
sampling probably for every edge you
sampled by that you get a sparse graph
he's like yeah I know you're worried
about these issues then of like how you
embed
back and forth so to get around that
just make sure probability edges
included
is at least some like 1 over K pick like
some parameter like whatever parameter
of how much you're trying to decrease
things just make sure you don't pick any
edge by too small in the mountain right
this won't solve your overall problem of
you know can you reduce solving on a
sparse graph but this will let you
decrease the number of edges in your
graph by a factor of K and make all the
progress you're trying to make so that
works out just fine you know if no edge
is larger didn't beds but you know if
you know edge is to much larger and
embeds back pretty trivially and that
that all just works out it was kind of
like a sentence or two and we went back
and forth many rounds until I could see
it so then you didn't stop there
so so he said okay so good so all this
flow sparse sapphire stuff of dealing
with sparse graphs you don't have to do
and then he also soon after that went
back through this entire framework and
the reason I presented it this way was
he showed us actually all of this stuff
it works not just in the case when
you're trying to minimize the worst
congestion in the edge but if instead
your optimal congestion you know if
instead of opt being the sum over all
you know sum over all the flows like the
L infinity norm of the flow the largest
of on any edge suppose you want to make
this the P norm he's like yeah you can
go through this same framework and make
it work out this becomes the P norm was
something we knew but hadn't wrote about
but then he showed that much cooler one
that you can still actually make this
type of reduction framework go through
which I if you try to think about a
little bit I think is rather non-trivial
as you know this picture that we had of
always knowing the worst case set of
demands that you would want to route
doesn't quite work through for the P
norm you have to come up with some other
proof that you're oblivious routing is
good with respect to the P norm this was
known that there were good of login'
competitive ratio oblivious writings for
all P norm but he showed you can kind of
get it through the same framework and
the same flow sparse afire stuff worked
out he also did some really cool stuff
we chat about when we chat about more
explored what norms you can actually get
a good oblivious routings for I think we
had a whole bunch of conjectures about
what this property the norm would
actually have for an oblivious trading
to exist and he ruled out some of them
but it didn't happen over gchat so I
haven't been able I have some people and
get to hunt down to figure out what he
did and then I guess I'll never know if
he did this if it genuinely showed up or
did it out of kindness he might have
seen the scene that I was a bit
disappointed that you didn't need to use
any of this flow sparsa fire machinery
so then he kept we're talking about
polishing all the boundaries of
everything and trying to get oblivious
routings very efficiently for all P
norms and he had a nice idea to do flow
sparsa fication in arbitrary LP norms in
a sketch of why you could do that and
argue in why you might actually need
flow smart need this sort of our
certification machinery I think one of
the highlights of talking with him about
this is we're talking about how you'd
maybe prove that things work and out of
nowhere he's like oh yeah just use
cheater and equality in the LP norm was
it was a not sure as part of the
literature but he had a way of modifying
everything so that you had cheater
inequality in the LP norm and we said it
was like a quick quick aside in some
conversation that then was like many
times chatting with him to actually work
out he also had added ideas for
explosive Arsuf occation to give faster
running times through a framework of
Sherman to get even faster flow
algorithms for different Delpy norms
which I thought was rather clever and
all along the way here I guess this idea
that he would you know try to really
hone in on what machinery was actually
needed what actually made it work and
finding sort of the cleanest
perspectives in which the it produced
was very characteristic of his work all
around
if I had more time I think even beyond
the list of talks there are today
there's all sorts of contributions he
made there's a whole line of working it
on geometric median I think that was one
of my favorite meetings with him where
out of nowhere this problem went from
looking like it might have some
structure to looking like could be very
very easy a whole bunch of things I wish
I paid better attention to when I was
teeing on the first year when you talked
about LP norms and a whole bunch of
stuff on how you would sample cycles
from directed graphs the list goes on
and on and on sorry I'm on time
thanks yeah I had like an LP norm
Rayleigh quotient I can talk to you
about it afterwards he had a way of like
bounding like LP operator norms from cut
properties yeah yeah I'm happy to talk
about that more